en la siguiente serie de vídeos voy a
hacer mi mejor esfuerzo por explicar la
crisis y el rescate financiero y voy a
explicar varios conceptos de formas
distintas y bueno espero que quede muy
claro viéndolo desde arriba hay un
montón de terminología por todos lados
pero los conceptos de fondo realmente no
son complicados un buen punto para
empezar es la hoja de balance puedes ver
algunos de los vídeos que hice sobre la
hoja de balance pero no hace ningún daño
que los repase aquí
entonces una hoja de balance es digamos
una foto de lo que tienes lo que bebes y
la diferencia entre sus dos y esa
diferencia es básicamente la riqueza que
te pertenece a ver un ejemplo de una
hoja de balance personal podríamos
escribir activos que significan cosas
que te darán un beneficio en el futuro
como por ejemplo digamos que tengo mil
pesos en efectivo
mil pesos en efectivo y tengo una casa
que vale digamos cien mil pesos
y entonces ahí está mi casa de cien mil
pesos y digamos que tengo un coche de
diez mil pesos
y digamos que cualquier otra cosa o sea
si viendo mis muebles mi televisión y el
resto de mis cosas digamos que puedo
obtener unos cinco mil pesos
entonces esos son mis activos cuál es el
valor total de todos mis activos pues si
sumamos todo esto lo que obtenemos son
116 mil pesos
bueno sería maravilloso vivir en un
mundo donde solo existían los activos
pero desgraciadamente también tenemos
los pasivos entonces pasivos aquí
y estas cosas en lugar de darnos
beneficios económicos como los activos
más bien nosotros tenemos que dar
beneficios económicos por ellos digamos
que estamos endeudados
entonces supongamos que tengo una deuda
de 20 mil pesos por un préstamo para la
universidad y digamos que de la casa que
yo tengo pues la compré pidiendo un
préstamo de 80 mil pesos al banco
y bueno vamos a agregarle un poco de
deuda en la tarjeta de crédito para que
sea un poco más real
y que sea una deuda de cinco mil pesos
ahora la mayoría de las casas valen
mucho más y el préstamo que tienen que
pedir para comprarla es también mucho
más grande pero bueno dejémoslo de un
lado cuánto valen mis activos menos mis
pasivos a ver vamos a calcular la
cantidad de los pasivos entonces este es
el total de mis activos
y cuáles son mis deudas cuántos son mis
pasivos pues son 105 mil pesos 105 mil
pesos en total de deudas de pasivos la
diferencia entre esos dos mis activos
menos mis pasivos eso es a lo que
nosotros le llamamos valor neto si fuera
yo liquidar todo vender todos mis
activos y pagar todos mis pasivos en mis
deudas eso es lo que tendría yo en las
manos
ese es mi valor neto y también le
podemos llamar capital muchas veces
escuchamos capital en contexto de una
casa y eso es nada más lo que vale la
casa menos la hipoteca que tenemos sobre
ello pero estamos hablando sobre mi hoja
de balance personal no es que realmente
te esté dando las cifras verdaderas no
quiero dar tanta información sobre mis
por el momento pero bueno cuál es la
diferencia entre sus dos números
y capital es básicamente 116 pesos menos
105 mil pesos y eso es 11 mil pesos en
total
ese es mi capital y lo escribió en verde
porque es un valor positivo y es bueno y
bueno seguro te encontrarás con personas
que tienen una casa de un millón de
pesos que digan guau yo tengo un millón
de pesos y bueno en realidad no tienen
un millón de pesos a menos que realmente
sean dueños de esa casa y pueden vender
la casa por un millón de pesos no se
trata de lo que pagaron por ella sino de
lo que el mercado está dispuesto a pagar
por ella pero bueno tu valor neto es tus
activos menos tus pasivos en este caso
es 11 mil pesos y no a 116 mil pesos y
esta es otra cosa importante o sea los
activos siempre son iguales a los
pasivos más el capital y eso sale
simplemente de la definición de capital
si te metes a una maestría en
administración de negocios que le llaman
mba lo escriben y se ve como una
ecuación activos es igual a pasivos más
capital pero
sucede así porque así lo definimos de
qué nos sirve todo esto pues hay algunas
cosas que podemos pensar o sea qué pasa
si mis pasivos osea mis deudas son más
grandes que mis activos y entonces yo le
debo más al mundo de lo que el mundo me
debe a mí entonces este número va a ser
negativo y si este el número es negativo
no hay ninguna buena razón bueno tal vez
para preservar mi puntaje de crédito
pero si sacamos los puntajes de crédito
de la ecuación entonces no hay ninguna
buena razón para que yo siga viviendo en
esta situación si mis deudas son más
grandes que mis activos
pensemos en este ejemplo supongamos que
mi casa solo vale 100 mil pesos pero por
alguna razón le debo 120 mil pesos al
banco por la casa o sea tal vez compre
la casa plazos por un total de 120 mil
pesos y ahora digo osea honestamente la
casa se ha devaluado y ahora solo vale
100 mil pesos entonces estoy en esta
situación
para una hipoteca y bueno número uno no
hay ningún beneficio por seguir pagando
la casa y viendo todo el panorama si veo
mi hoja de balance cuánto valdrán mis
pasivos abra mis pasivas valen 145 mil
pesos en este caso y mi capital o sea
mis activos menos mis pasivos son 116
mil menos 145 mil o sea vamos a
escribirlo en rojo porque es un muy mal
número son menos 29 mil pesos ahora en
esta situación realmente no hay razón
para la que yo quiera seguir viviendo de
la forma en la que estoy viviendo al
menos financieramente o sea no se trata
de cambiar la forma en la que respiras
ni mucho menos pero bueno no hay ninguna
razón para no ir a buscar protección
para la bancarrota es decir declararse
en quiebra
decir soy insolvente admitir que no hay
forma en la que yo pueda pagar todas
estas deudas las leyes me protegen
mi casero no me puede perseguir van a
borrar todo esto van a tomar todos mis
activos
entre las personas a las que les debo
dinero esta es la bancarrota la
insolvencia quiero remarcar esta palabra
insolvencia
insolvencia porque eso es algo de lo que
vamos a hablar cuando hablemos de la
crisis de crédito y eso esto es muy
distinto a la falta de liquidez entonces
qué es lo que es la falta de liquidez la
insolvencia es que no hay ninguna razón
para que tú sigas viviendo con esta
situación económica estás en la quiebra
tienes que pedir protección para la
bancarrota eso es la insolvencia la
falta de liquidez es a ver déjame déjame
regreso la situación original
donde en lugar de ver 120.000 de la casa
debía 80 mil pesos de la casa
y entonces mis pasivos valen 105 mil
pesos y entonces en serio tengo un
capital positivo 11 mil pesos
pero digamos a ver esto esto fue
insolvencia y voy a describir lo que la
falta de liquidez significa para ti o
para mí porque este es mi hoja de
balance entonces digamos que no sé o sea
mi esposo y llega de la nada y me dice
que tenemos que pagar la colegiatura a
nuestro hijo y que son cinco mil pesos
de colegiatura para el próximo mes o sea
tengo que pagar cinco mil pesos
pagar cinco mil pesos
bueno déjame busco un mejor ejemplo
porque si estamos hablando de la
colegiatura tiene que aparecer en los
pasivos entonces digamos que tengo que
hacer un pago de cinco mil pesos de mi
préstamo para la colegiata de la
universidad que de repente su fecha
límite para pagarse es mañana y lo tengo
que pagar ahorita
entonces a ver tengo que pagar cinco mil
pesos y puede ser para cualquier cosa
pero digamos que es para satisfacer uno
de estos pasivos entonces si te fijes en
mi capital osea mis activos menos mis
pasivos claramente tengo once mil pesos
y si pudiera liquidar todos mis activos
y mis pasivos de la noche a la mañana
tendría once mil pesos en efectivo y
podría pagar esos cinco mil pesos de
hecho en el proceso los habría pagado
aquí en los veinte mil pesos pero en
esta circunstancia como la fecha el
límite para pagar esos cinco mil pesos
es mañana y solo tengo mil pesos en
efectivo tal vez en el banco o debajo
del colchón no puedo pagar esos cinco
mil pesos solo con mi efectivo entonces
veo el resto de mis cosas y digo ok
puedo utilizar una de ellas y claro que
no o sea la casa por ejemplo ok tal vez
pueden contar a alguien que me pague 15
mil pesos por ella mañana pero eso no
ayudaría mi situación o sea entonces
tendría un capital negativo y eso no me
ayudaría nada lo mismo con el carro tal
vez podrá encontrar alguien que me
pagaría cuatro mil pesos por mi coche
hoy pero no quiero hacer eso tampoco y
de mis muebles porque ahí tendría que
tomar las fotos subirlos al mercado
libre de internet no podría hacerlo
entonces esta es una situación de crisis
de liquidez te falta liquidez pero no
eres insolvente o sea tienes un capital
positivo asumiendo que no estás
mintiendo en tu hoja de balance y como
sobrevive es una crisis de liquidez pues
alguien tiene que darte un le llamamos
préstamo puente porque te están dando un
puente para ir de aquí a donde necesitas
llegar te están dando un puente que te
da tiempo digamos tu papá te dice ok te
voy a dar un préstamo de cinco mil pesos
por los próximos dos meses y dentro de
dos meses espero que hayas encontrado
alguna forma de obtener ese efectivo
vendes tu coche o tus muebles o algo así
ese es un préstamo para prevenir la
crisis
y ese préstamo no sería una mala idea
porque si esta persona realmente no está
mintiendo sobre su hoja de balance y yo
no estoy mintiendo sobre mi hoja de
balance entonces en realidad si podría
conseguir yo el dinero por otro lado ese
préstamo sería una muy mala idea si yo
fuera insolvente sería como tirar dinero
a un pozo sin fondo o sea no puedo pagar
mis deudas y me acaba de dar otro
préstamo que no voy a poder pagar bueno
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo